Would you have to get a new snake?
Was that your responsibility?
We had a guy in a Stamford,
Connecticut.
He was Charles Manson revisited.
This guy was a freak,
rather Stanford,
Connecticut to weird place.
He had a farm in down Connecticut and they did not know that he had over a
thousand snakes in that farm on the building.
And about 150 of them are poisonous.
Nope.
Cause he was collecting venom for different,
for different pharmaceutical companies.
But uh,
I remember one time having to get a snake from it and he flipped through,
uh,
Omaha and you know,
he'd been working with me for a couple of years.
So Albert,
man,
we'll take care of you tonight.
Brilliant.
What is it Jake?
I'm like,
I'm going to take you to a strip joint.
He's like,
it's not necessary.
I'm like,
I know it's not necessarily,
hey bro,
let me take you out.
So we get there,
man.
I use just kind of like sitting there and was heading down towards the table
looking at his beer and drank my job.
And I'm like,
I don't get this motherfucker going,
you know.
So the dude,
you pick her out,
if you'll take a price,
I'll pay for it.
It was on binds and blessing.
He goes,
oh,
Jake,
just coming and take my snakes,
man.
Whoa.
Excuse me.
I just want to go back to the room and play with my snake coming
and won't change rooms.
Different floor.
Wow.
Yeah.
He was a real freaking mess in the snakes.
Is he still alive?
Yeah,
he is.
He was enough Florida when that pet hurricane hit down there and he was working
in a gator farm and poisonous snake venom collection point and they had like 800
snakes down there.
Right.
So the hurricane hits and just fucking levels of place.
One calling for days,
trying to get ahold of him.
See if he's all right.
I'm finally get a hold of me.
I'm like,
dude,
what are you so fucking happy?
Because it was best time of my life,
man.
This is fucking like God's made this.
Especially for me.
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
He goes,
I get to find all those snakes.
You get to find them.
Let me think.
You're going to dig through all that Shit,
all that shit and a lift up stuff and stick your hand down and holes and shit to
find these poisons sakes.
Yeah,
man,
it's cool.
I'm like,
fuck you all for your fucked up.
What is it with Florida and snakes,
Connecticut,
man,
whatever.
I know,
but he went to Florida.
It's like it draws them there like a magnet.
He was in Connecticut men and they asked him to go do anything for the boy's
Club,
you know,
introduce them to snakes and blah,
blah,
blah.
It'd be great,
you know,
for the eight to 12 year olds.
So he gets in there and he's talking to him about this
Mexican rattler.
Now,
first thing you know about snakes exists,
it can be poisonous and a poisonous snakes.
Children.
What happens there?
They're not healthy.
They weren't you.
They can kill you.
Yes,
that's right.
So that's why you should always your,
oh,
oh my God.
Oh,
hold on.
Okay,
look,
he's accidentally bit me.
Ah,
you know,
I've been bitten now,
so I do what I'm gonna do something they call nine one one we're going to,
I'm just going to explain to you what I'm feeling right now.
So if you ever get bitten,
you'll know what you're going to expect to feel after you've been bitten.
When he fucking with these.
No,
no there fees.
Fucking Biden,
man.
Yeah,
he's fucked.
And he knows that he's fucked because here's the thing about Mexican
rattlesnakes,
not many of those in Connecticut.
So you don't have any yet,
do you?
Oh Jesus.
No,
they got to fly it in from fucking,
you know,
it Atlanta or wherever.
So by the time they get that shit out there to me and he's fucked up and they
went up and they cut all the meat off one of his bones on his finger.
So you've got like this gnarly,
so he had a necropsy,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
I've seen a video or a website rather detailing this kid is horse bid in the
arm.
No meet Bruce had to get him somewhere to safety,
but it took hours.
Med Vac,
I'm and a helicopter,
his whole arm rotted away down to the bone so they had to take meat from his
leg,
get it off and put,
you know,
they had to do skin graphs all over.
I think you went through like 16 operations.
She was awful.
They had a stitch them all together like pull the meat of his arm together and
stitch it all together.
I mean it was a giant 10 to 12 inch patch of his arm was gone.
Yeah,
it fucks you up.
Plus it's a really cool looking thing that it does is it causes all the small
capillaries in your eyes to burst.
I don't choose show your eyes are like blood red except they're bumpy.
You know like he would close his eyes and I run my finger over his eyelid and
you just feel all these little bumps in crevices and Dan is weird how long it
take for him to recover.
He's in the hospital for a couple of weeks,
man.
He was a,
I hate to put him in a coma for like six days.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Lethally such a cool cool.
Is He,
does he have a tolerance to regular venom?
Cause I know a lot of those guys building a tolerance to different ones.
Yeah,
they make themselves get bit.
Yeah.
Cobra.
I think he's pretty much clean on this guy.
Sounds like he's going to end up being a super villain of some kind.
Just so he could be mad.
Cause I swear to God he is Charles Manson.
Wow.
He looks like Charles Manson looks weird.
Like anyone.
He smiles just like,
dude,
that is not healthy.
You know,
he didn't,
you know fuck man.
Wow.
He's a true,
imagine what this guy would be like without snakes.
Thank God snakes exists.
Well you have the steamboat,
you know,
come up with a Komodo dragon thing,
to,
to come back to snake back in the day.
So of course that's who Albert Albert was the guy with the Komodo dragons.
So he,
he had some pot that he was growing up in the mountains and he took one of the
dragons with him
to get it out in the sunlight.
So they put it in this fucking station wagon and they go up in the mountains and
they actually walk to their place where they get their stuff growing.
So they close the car door up,
leave the window down about that much take off,
come back window's busted.
Oh,
Jesus.
Or GS.
Horrible teeth marks on all of it in this fucking Komodo Dragon.
Mature in his way out of this shit.
He was in a wooden Katie.
He chewed his way out of the wooden case.
He got out,
man.
It took off.
I guess it's about two months later,
man.
I was like in Indianapolis and waking up and listen to the news and the ESPN
zone or like what was thought to be a prehistoric monster was found running
across the backyard and Miss Gibbons House chasing her port,
a little poodle.
When we get back,
see our monster.
Wow.
They come back and I'm sitting on what the fuck pull to be prehistoric.
I've gotten,
I'm going to see this shit in the fucking thing comes back up.
I'm like,
that's fucking Albert's fucking thing,
man.
It's the thing that had escaped two months later.
It gained like 35 pounds and everybody's dogs and cats in the neighborhood,
man.
And couple of kids too.
Who knows such a ruthless animal,
you know,
those are so ruthless that the little baby Komodo dragons smear shit on
themselves so that the grownups don't eat them so that their parents don't eat
them.
They roll around and shit so that their parents don't eat them because uh,
when Komodo dragons are eating intestines,
they shake the shit out of and test it.
They don't like to eat shit.
As weird as that is that after this bad attitude,
I had a problem with cocaine.
I imagine that they eat their fucking kids so the kids know this.
So they,
they somehow or another like no,
to smear themselves and shit.
I'd learned pretty quick.
Yeah.
You see your sister get chewed out,
right?
You see them avoid shit but eat your sister.
You're like,
that shit is salvation.
You some good shit.
It gained 30 pounds.
That's fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Let it loose in Florida.
They wouldn't even notice.
Fuck no,
no.
Everything else they got down.
Yeah.
That the Florida everglades,
it's so crazy with pythons,
man,
so,
so bad that they're eating alligators.
They did this study.
They found that they couldn't find any raccoons.
They couldn't find any swamp rabbits or march hares,
I guess they called them.
Yeah.
Everything got killed by python.
So then the pythons moved on to alligators.
Yeah.
Alligators.
Look around,
man.
I've got a picture of an anaconda swallowing an 800 pound horse.
Why?
It's got the head in the front legs already chewed up inside of the last
picture.
You know,
I need it.
I'll get you.
I need that fucking Croesus Shit,
man.
See if he could find that.
Jamille powers bodies like this big place with his back.
He probably can't pull it up.
Ah,
Jamie,
he's coming at you hard and whip it.
I bet.
In all your years you never thought Jake,
the snake would be roasting.
You live on the Internet.
I believed that and nail and Steve back injury and nailing up.
Pull it up.
Reference.
Yeah,
I got you,
Bro.
I'm not just a short face to pretty dick
short digging a pretty face.
That's it.